il était une fois une princesse pas
comme les autres
moi s'est-il
ses griffes et elle est touffu et voilà
dayton
bienvenue dans ma ville rende rhume
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les baiseurs céline dounia la rue
alors on doit se débrouiller tout seul
voilà j'ai pris
un beau jour il a fallu que je me
déguise très chatte hello garde depuis
tout le monde me propres pour résister
salut on dirait que dès que pour la
gauche
ni le cruel régentry star a empoisonné
notre prince
et la transformer vos proches à poules
mouillées charmante épouse
[Musique]
il me faudra du courage
et surtout n'allez pas dans l'ombre
attendez il va y avoir des trucs
dangereux
si l'on fait du ballon petit choc
pado
je suis la seule à pouvoir sauver le
royaume
personne ne peut s'opposer à boire
grenoble aix c'est eux qu'on a dans le
coeur
fils
on est en sécurité ici
ah bah non le 11 août au cinéma